what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
i'm still coming down from the
spider-man no way home teaser trailer
hype
hello peter
let's be honest i think it's going to be
a while until most of us come down from
it and if you haven't heard the
spider-man no way home teaser trailer
broke the record for most online views
in its first 24 hours after release
which is insane but not unexpected it
got 355.5
million views worldwide topping the
total of 289 million views for the first
trailer for avengers endgame so needless
to say i think people are pretty dang
excited for this film and this is just
the teaser can you imagine if they
actually put all three spider-man on
screen in a trailer for a significant
amount of time i think that would easily
beat this teaser so it doesn't look like
the hype is going to stop anytime soon
which i know a lot of people really
don't have a problem with and if you're
here in this video right now that means
you would like to know more about the
plot of spider-man no way home i must
issue however a spoiler warning i am
about to talk about the actual plot for
spider-man no way home there are going
to be spoilers in it if you've been
following me and my spider-man videos
you know that a lot of the leaks that
i've been talking about are true they
were confirmed true by the teaser
trailer the same thing goes for these
plot details that i'm going to be
revisiting and breaking down right now
so you have been warned i think a good
majority of you have probably heard this
one before so i'm just going to read
through it and then we'll talk about it
and connect it to the trailer afterwards
it says peter's life is ruined after his
identity was revealed at the end of the
last mysterio movie also keep in mind
that this is literally somebody
explaining it to another person it says
he is now facing trial matt murdock is
his lawyer peter goes to doctor strange
and asks him to cast a spell to make
everyone forget that he is spider-man
however something goes wrong with the
spell and they break reality and bring
five spider villains of other dimensions
to the mcu the green goblin from the
first spider-man film doc ock from
spider-man 2 the sandman from the third
spider-man film the lizard from the
amazing spider-man and electro from the
amazing spider-man 2. norman osborne aka
the green goblin is talking to the
others asking what is the last thing
they remember and they all say
spider-man killed them doctor strange
wants to take them back to their
original dimensions but the villains
fear that returning would mean that they
would return exactly where they came
from meaning they would die again peter
wants to let them free because he feels
bad because the other spider-man in the
other universes killed them he wants to
set them free and norman osborne
manipulates peter into feeling sorry for
them and he frees them peter fights
doctor strange and breaks the key which
is a cube that held them captive and the
villains are now free if you caught my
breakdown you can remember that i
mentioned the cuban that it was very
important i didn't remember exactly what
it was at the time but now i do thanks
to this plot leak it is the key that
keeps them in the prison but peter
breaks it the villains are now free and
they start destroying parts of new york
and to stop them peter somehow brings
toby maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man to the mcu to help him there
is a big rematch between toby maguire
spider-man and doc ock and between
andrew garfield spider-man and electro
the final battle is at the statue of
liberty with the three spider-men
fighting together fighting the sinister
six and this person says to be clear i
have no idea who the sixth member is or
when or how they come into the scene so
as you can probably tell this is the
plot of spider-man no way home pretty
much all of this was confirmed in the
very first teaser trailer now obviously
it's a teaser trailer and it's not going
to show all of this but it did actually
show quite a good majority of this we
did see all of these villains or at
least saw some part of them and the
villain that we were questioning if it
was lizard or not i believe it now is
because of this plot leak because keep
in mind i was sent this like three weeks
ago maybe a month ago i did a video on
it we can go back and find that video
but it was way before the teaser trailer
and everything in it is accurate which
also means for some doubters out there
which i totally understand but it also
means that toby maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield spider-man are indeed
coming and it sounds like they're going
to definitely have their hands full
helping our mcu's peter parker now this
actually does help clear up a few things
in the teaser trailer there is one
specific scene where we see doctor
strange and peter on a train doctor
strange is performing some crazy cool
magic and a lot of people were wondering
if they're fighting here and now the
answer looks like yes but the other
question was who are they fighting and
the answer is they're fighting each
other and to me it's kind of funny
because it's like sorry peter but you
stand no chance against doctor strange
and we can see that in this footage
doctor strange takes the train that
they're on and duplicates it and sends
them off into the sky he's the master of
the mystic arts sorry peter you don't
really have a chance here but of course
they're going to be allies i don't
believe that they're going to actually
be enemies throughout the movie this
will probably be a pretty epic fight and
then after doctor strange is going to
say something like well we have to get
them back and since they're destroying
new york and they truly are evil as
peter can see he's probably going to
agree now another thing this confirms is
that matt murdock aka daredevil is going
to be peter's lawyer in the beginning in
my breakdown i put a few photos of this
mysterious person and it really really
does look like matt murdock and since
this leak has been pretty accurate so
far i'm gonna go ahead and say yes that
is him and this leak actually confirms
something that alfred molina said in a
recent interview about returning as doc
ock yes he did give it away he straight
up just told everybody yeah i'm
returning for spider-man no way home he
even said that he had a conversation
with the director about how he was going
to return when he was dead which the
director replied in this universe no
one's really dead and obviously with the
multiverse that's true and he said that
he was going to be taken from that
moment at the very end when he is
sinking into the water which means he's
going to be taken right before he dies
and we can assume that this is going to
be true for the other villains as well
this is confirmed when norman osborne
asks everybody what's the last thing you
remember and they all say spider-man
killing them except for the sandman
because he did not die which is actually
why i believe and some other people do
as well that he's going to be good in
the trailer we actually see sand with
the lightning and that could be him
actually trying to protect peter parker
at the end of spider-man 3 sandman and
peter parted ways peacefully peter
parker said i forgive you and sandman
was just trying to do it for his
daughter now this says that the final
battle is going to take place on the
statue of liberty and it's going to be
the three spider-man versus the sinister
six and we've actually seen a leaked
photo of the statue of liberty holding a
captain america shield and this was from
the set of spider-man no way home so we
can also believe that that is indeed
going to be the final scene and the last
thing i want to talk about is something
that is very key pun intended to
spider-man knowing home which is the
cube key that doctor strange has that
peter breaks i've heard a little bit of
rumblings around about what this key
actually does and it's pretty much like
it says it keeps the villains trapped
inside of some sort of magical prison
the only thing i'm really unclear of
right now is whether or not the villains
kind of just pop out of the middle of
the air then doctor strange goes and he
retrieves them and he puts them in the
prison or if they pop up in the sanctum
somehow that's kind of a part that i'm
unclear of but i would really love to
see doctor strange fight these villains
i also heard that doctor strange somehow
gets hurt and he needs his power to kind
of rebuild the key or keep it together
because that's how they're going to get
them back to their respective universes
and that's why doctor strange is kind of
going to be out of the picture and not
going to be able to help peter parker
which is why the other peter parker's
come in and i know a lot of people were
saying well we really want our
spider-man tom hall and spider-man to
kind of go into his own character not
really get help and i do think we are
going to see that in this film i do
think at some point doctor strange will
kind of be taken out of the picture and
it's really just going to be about him
and it's going to be his decision to
bring the other spider-man in and it's
going to be his decision on what to do
with the villains i do think he's really
going to grow up here but so far that i
know that is the most accurate plot
details that we have again i got it way
before the trailer came out and when the
trailer came out it proved most of it
real so be sure to let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below and if you're new consider
subscribing to the channel to stay up to
date on spiderman news and of course mcu
news for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof